my name is Patrick Steele item and today
I'm going to talk about Marco and how
it's a perfect fit for nodejs alright so
just a little bit about myself I work
for eBay as a UI platform lead I do I
have I worked a lot on open source I
have quite a few projects that I'm
involved in Marco is probably the
biggest project that I work on but I
also have another project called lasso
and morph Tom and I'm definitely an open
source enthusiast I spend a lot of time
helping people in the open-source
community and I try to get more people
to contribute to open source so I
mentioned I work for eBay and the reason
I want to talk about eBay is because we
just built Marco at eBay and open
sourced it and we designed it to be have
the skill that we need a eBay so eBay
does have a lot of scale like we have
lots of transactions this is just to
give you an idea of how much how the
transactions that we deal with at eBay
so our website is critical for our
business and the reason I say that is
because we switched our stack recently
to use from a Java based stack over to
using nodejs entirely on the front end
so we're doing server-side rendering and
we're also using no GS for all of our
tooling to do all the bundling of all
our JavaScript CSS and we're of course
we're using it also to do our HTML
rendering using Marco so what does our
stack look like so I mentioned we
transition from Java so we used to use
JSP as our the view layer Java stack so
we used allowed jQuery because that was
big back in the days but we've moved
over to completely using nodejs and that
means we get to use JavaScript on both
the server side and in the browser and
instead of jsps we get to use Marco so
quick question who here has heard of
Marco before this talk okay it's few
people so it's relatively new so I'm
going to kind of go through why we built
Marco and how we're using it eBay but
first I want to talk a little bit more
about nodejs usage at eBay so we've
really ramped up our usage of nodejs at
eBay pretty much every part of the site
is reading rebuilt in nodejs so wherever
if there's any big rewrites we we moved
from the Java stack the old Java stack
to no js' and we're currently on node 6
X will probably switch to a 20 comes the
long-term support release we have well
over 200 applications and it's
continuously growing we actually have a
small platform team so I'm part of the
node.js platform team but it really is
just a group of seven developers but we
collaborate really we've built a model
of collaboration within the company so
that everyone's working together so it's
this whole idea of like internal open
source so the platform is not just owned
by the platform team so we currently
have about 80 platform modules built for
nodejs to solve things like security or
of its experimentation or global header
different things that we needed to have
a baseline application that's production
ready at eBay and we have well over 330
modules that are built by all the
different teams and published to our
internal NPM registry within eBay so
this is just an overview of the stack at
eBay so at the bottom we're using nodejs
on top of that the primary things that
we have are Marco for the view layer we
are using lasso which is similar to web
pack but we're using that as the asset
pipeline for JavaScript module bundling
CSS bundling and just general images and
fonts and think assets like that we're
also using Express just for the basic
request response pipeline and middle
where we have our platform modules that
build on top of those technologies and
then it's the application code so the
web applications at the the product
teams are building which includes like
pages UI components as well as any
services that talk to our middle tier
that's typically implemented in Java but
we're also exploring implementing our
middle tier in nodejs
alright so no js' has always had this
concept of streams streams have been
built into like no GS core and it gives
you the ability to do like send down
chunks of data to in a direction so it's
a powerful thing and you can also use
streams for HTML so you can stream HTML
down to the browser to improve page load
times so streaming is actually a
prerequisite for progressive HTML
and for those who don't know what
progressive rational rendering is it's
this idea that you break up your
rendering and you start flushing things
in multiple chunks so instead of for
example waiting for all of your back-end
services to complete and then rendering
your page synchronously and sending down
one HTML chunk you can do it
incrementally and this is a technique
that allows the browser to start
fetching things earlier start painting
the page earlier so that the user can
actually see if perceived increase in
page load time but also an actual
improvement so streaming is powerful and
especially helpful with HTML rendering
but it's only helpful if you're actually
going to do asynchronous rendering if
you've just written in your page
synchronously where basically you fetch
all your data asynchronously and then
you render synchronously then it's
better to just send down a single chunk
that's gzip compressed and the reason I
say that is because I've seen different
you view libraries out there that try to
introduce streaming but it's really if
without the asynchronous rendering it's
not gonna help so here's a page that I
want to kind of illustrate how we can
benefit from progressive HTML rendering
and streaming so in this page we have
five different parts we have a header we
have a search result which in this case
we're gonna say the search results is
going to be the slowest part of the page
so it may depend on a back-end service
the search results search service that
it lets say takes a second so it's going
to be slow and then you have ads and
filters which depend on separate
services and those might take less time
and then at the end we have the footer
so this timeline shows what you can how
you can improve the page loading time by
taking advantage of progressive HTML
rendering so the first bar is if you
just wait for all the backend services
to complete and that's gonna be the
slowest one which is be the search
results service so basically the users
gonna see a blank page for about one
second and then the browser is going to
finally get some HTML and then at that
point once the browser gets the HTML it
can then start fetching all the CSS all
the JavaScript that's needed to make
that page work and then the user is
actually going to see the page be
painted in the web browser so we can do
better than that we can take advantage
of progressive HTML rendering to start
fetching
that all the back-end data but start
rendering the page and because the
header doesn't depend on any back-end
services we can start we can flush that
immediately down but then you get to the
search results which are the second part
in the page and we have to wait the one
second if we want to for that to
complete but we can still render all the
other parts of the page and they will
complete sooner but we don't want to
necessarily send them down before the
browser before the search results
because then you're going to be sending
things out of order so the server can
buffer up those parts of your page and
then finally when the search results
service comes back we can then send down
the search results part of the page as
well as the ads and all the other parts
including the footer so that's a little
better
but we can even do better than that by
using out of order flushing so what that
means is that we were going to flush
down each of those parts of the page as
soon as those back-end services complete
and we can start painting the browser
can then receive that HTML and show it
to the user
by updating the browser and also if you
flush down immediately the CSS and
everything you can start fetching those
things as well but if you have a
situation where parts of the page
complete out of order the what we can do
is we can put a loading indicator so
that the user knows that this part of
the page is not ready and then when we
do flush it we can actually when it part
of the page comes in we actually put
JavaScript code into the output stream
that will then move that part of the the
fragment of the page into the proper
location and this technique which we
call out of order progressive HTML
rendering gives us the best load time
for our users which is important for
companies like eBay because it's been
shown that of course if improving page
load times can increase the number of
transactions and on a related note at
eBay server-side rendering is very
important for us because it allows us to
maximize reduce the time it takes to
paint the initial page for in the
browser and it also is great for SEO
alright so these are great techniques
very few applications in the wild
actually take advantage of HTM
streaming and progressive HTML rendering
even though it's something that's so
easy to do with nodejs and a reason for
this at least one reason for this is
that a lot of people use express an
express has this this built-in support
for a view engines and the API for
register new view engines is always a
single call back so it's not compatible
at all with streaming so if you can't if
that's what everyone uses an intern occu
bill to take take advantage of
progressive HTML rendering so that
wasn't acceptable eBay so we looked to
an alternative turns out even if you use
Express or Co or if don't use a web
framework at all you don't have to use
the view engine part you if you have
access to the response the writable
response stream you can use that to take
advantage of streaming and progressive
HTML rendering so I want to shift focus
of talking about Marco so Marco I
mentioned is what the open source
project that I work on and it's a
template engine but it's it's actually a
lot more than that so it does HTML
rendering on the server side in the
browser but it also has UI components
the isomorphic part is one reason that
we're using nodejs they have the same
code running on both the the same api at
least running on both the serve in the
browser simplifies how developers build
pages they don't have to think about do
I do this on the server or do this in
the browser it doesn't matter so the
same API you can seamlessly move between
the two so on the server we wanted to be
able to do streaming so I so we want to
be able to async and streaming rendering
but in the browser if you're rendering
the page in the browser it's different
you don't actually want to produce HTML
streams you want to render to something
that allows you to more efficiently
update the Dom because if you were to
render to a stream then you have to
parse the string to get back the actual
Dom that can then be used to update the
the real Dom so by optimizing for both
the server-side rendering and the
browser side rendering use case we were
able to offer best-in-class performance
on both the server side and in the
browser and this makes it Marco a great
fit for like even like constrained
devices like mobile devices that are
older but also it allows us to
be more efficient with our server-side
utilization of resources but we designed
Marco because it is an it's it's an a
templating engine it's it's a new
language but we want to keep it as
simple as possible so we want to stay as
close to HTML and JavaScript as possible
so on the right hand side you see a code
fragment of Marco that illustrates a
single file UI component so in this file
we've combined the client-side behavior
which is in that class section and the
styling which is in the Style section
and at the bottom you just write pretty
much HTML with some added shorthand so
instead of saying class equals you can
just do dot the class name and this
matches up with how people are with CSS
selectors but otherwise it should be
pretty straightforward and readable so
Marco is a it has a long history oh and
we've been evolving it constantly to
basically keep up with we look at what's
happening in the space like we look at
react and view inferno and we bring in
all the good ideas into marco to make
sure that it's something that is staying
innovative and cutting-edge so it's
grown a lot and a big milestone for us
was the marco v4 release which was a
huge effort involving a lots of
different developers both both within
ebay and outside eBay and then we found
that after the v4 release we've saw a
significant increase in the community
and we've get a lot more questions we
have a very active git er chat room
which is works really well if you ever
want to just reach out to any other core
team or get help from other people who
are using Marco so right now we have
over 50 contributors for Marco but also
there's an entire ecosystem around Marco
we have tools for plugins we have
command-line tools
so within eBay though we've we've pretty
much every team that's building on the
nodejs tacky ebay is using marco so we
now have over 13,000 UI components and
pages so it's been very heavily
battle-tested at eBay and we're we've
definitely see other companies outside
EJ adopting Marco and we hope to keep
see that trend continue
so it can vary but right now we can we
have easily well over a thousand a
billion rather sorry billion URLs per
day being rendered going through mark
one or nodejs stack alright so how
exactly is Marco being used at eBay so
we recently migrated our homepage from
the the old Java stack over to no J
stack using Marco which is they have
most heavily used page at eBay so this
was basically if we can if the eBay
homepage can support it can work using
Marco and we did see significant
increases in performance then I feel
it's we can confidently say that Marco
can scale to any use case and because no
js' does makes it so easy to do
asynchronous we found that the patterns
that noj's provides makes it that the
node.js application actually perform
better than the equivalent java
application honestly because it was
faster than Java
so we're also using marco for the for
the mobile website so the mobile website
you we want to keep it as lean as fast
as possible and marco was a great fit
there because we kept the the library
size for Marco's like less than 10 kg
zip it varies based on which feature to
use but it's it's tiny it's also really
fast
so it works really well for creating
mobile websites so I want to kind of go
into why Marco is a really good fit for
nodejs
because we built Marco from the
beginning to work with nodejs
and also the browser all right so Marco
is distributed on NPM and it's not
distributed via via a CDN because of the
modular nature of it we didn't want to
say that there's this pre bundled build
of Marco so the best way to use Marco is
to just do NPM install of the Marco
package into your project or you can
actually use the the new MPX command to
use our Marco CLI to create a new app
that pulls in Marco and it's kind of
like a starter kit so it hides all the
boilerplate from you so I would
encourage you to check out they try that
second command there MPX
co-ceo and then create and then your app
name alright so node.js has always had
this concept of modules so you can
import modules into your another module
and make use of it very easily and the
nice thing about modules is you can keep
modules close to where they're being
used you can also install modules into
your node modules directory from NPM and
they had this great way of resolving
paths and everything so we didn't want
we to increase and introduce some new
way of having like namespace templates
or anything like that we want to really
embrace the modularity that nodejs gives
us so you can import a Marco template
just like any other JavaScript modules
because when a Marco template gets
compiled it compiles into a JavaScript
module and you can then have a variable
to use that that Marco template in your
code so this hopefully makes it a little
clearer how you can use marco to
actually render your HTML so you import
the template into your JavaScript module
and you can then the template exposes an
API so there's multiple methods you can
call dot stream and you can pass any
data that you want to pass to your
template and get back a readable stream
that you can then pipe for to this
example like you can pipe it to an HTP
HTTP response stream you could pipe it
to a file whatever you a file stream or
you can render directly to a writable
stream such as a response dream alright
so I mentioned earlier that we want to
keep Marco as simple as possible to
reduce the learning curve and this meant
embracing HTML and JavaScript wherever
possible we didn't want to feel like a
new language even though there are areas
where you definitely you know we
introduced certain features into Marco
but what I want to emphasize here is
that JavaScript is is a big part of
Marco so you we you can import a
JavaScript module using the JavaScript
import syntax into it so you can import
helpers into your templates you can if
you put a dollar sign at the beginning
of a line you switch out of HTML parsing
mode into JavaScript mode so you
can easily like create variables or in
call functions inside your Marco
templates so it's kind of like if you
want to compare to react react starts
with JavaScript and makes it more like
HTML Marco takes HTML and makes it more
like JavaScript but in the end they kind
of meet in the middle but we feel that
starting with HTML reduces the
boilerplate significantly and it also
gives the compiler a lot more
opportunity to optimize the code because
it's generating the JavaScript code in
the end so the compiler can do a lot of
optimizations which I go into a little
more detail later
the other cool thing is that with HTML
attributes are limited to strings which
is a terrible limitation we want to
break away from that so instead of HTML
attributes being strings they're always
parsed as JavaScript expressions so
wherever you see so if it's in quotes
it's still going to be a string but you
can also pass in boolean's numbers or
complex JavaScript expressions as you
see here in this example where we say
class equals and it's a complex but it's
just JavaScript so and the last place
where you can use javascript is inside
the dollar sign curly braces so you can
do like placeholder inside your the text
body of your HTML all right so so I
talked the earlier talk in the earlier
in the talk I talked about async and
streaming so from the beginning Marco
had support for async rendering which
allowed you to render parts of your your
output asynchronously and Marco handles
the hard part of flushing out the HTML
in the correct order or buffering or out
of order flushing but it's all handled
by Marco so there's this a weight tag
that you can pass it a promise so this
promise can be of course like you can
make a back-end call using async await
and you can get back a promise and you
can pass that promise directly to your
front-end and when that promise resolves
to a value it will then render that
portion of the template and it will
store the value that promise into a
variable that you give it so here we're
storing person promise in a variable
named person so that that is that's how
easy it is to do a syncretic so it's not
hard it's like it's it's really
intuitive
so another great thing about nodejs is
its it's all about modularity in
composing large applications from a
bunch of small modules and a large part
of that is the you have NPM of course
but also the module loading system so
import/export so in HTML world the
equivalent would be like having custom
tags where you can basically call out to
this custom tag is like a black box that
takes care of rendering this portion of
your page so Marco has built-in support
for custom elements that you can just
drop into your HTML template and I'll
explain a little more later how you can
actually how you can create these new
custom elements very easily another
thing a nice feature of Marco and this
is kind of borrowed from people who flew
a jade or pug is that you can use all
the angle brackets in the standard HTML
syntax or you can go with the
indentation based syntax which we call
the concise syntax so basically you drop
all the ending tags you dropped all the
angle brackets but otherwise it's
identical to the HTML syntax so you can
switch between the two and it varies
some teams like the concise syntax some
teams at eBay prefer the traditional
HTML syntax just because it's what
they're used to but you can actually we
have a pretty printer tool so you can
switch between the syntax is very easily
so but it varies some people do like the
concise syntax all right so I mentioned
the single-file UI components so Marco
is I mentioned it's more than just a
templating engine we really want to
solve the hard problem of not only just
rendering HTML but also handling
updating the Dom so if something changes
like the input changes or the state
changes then you need to update the Dom
and marco has built-in support for dom
dipping and patching similar to what
react has and then also styling is
another part of the UI component so you
can choose to put your styling into the
marco file or you can split it out into
another file next to the marco called
like style dot CSS and marco will
automatically pull those styles in when
it sends down the code down to the
browser the other thing i want to point
out here is that you can see how we use
on click to attach
eventlistener for the HTML Dom click
event and basically you can bind a Dom
event to a method on your UI component
there's also support for custom events
so if you were to put an event listener
on a custom element that would be a
custom event versus a native Dom event
all right so a little bit about project
structure so we've worked with a lot of
teams that eBay and getting the project
structure right was really important so
how you organize your code matters a lot
traditionally I've seen and it's less
common these days people would fork like
they'd have one directory for views
another for controllers another one for
models and it was like this like weird
like splitting of your assets into
separate top-level directories so we
didn't want that we wanted you to
organize your code based on like
functional area so you'd have like user
profile or search results so very much
focus on one specific thing and all the
things relate to that would be right
there in that same directory so
components are one of the things where
you have like multiple routes in your
page and you're sorry multiple routes in
your application and you might also have
each route might have its own set of UI
components you might have a set of
shared UI components or you might have
UI components that are pulled in from a
separate NPM package so Marko supports
this idea of scoped component
directories so it's very similar it was
inspired by node modules so whenever you
require a module that's not a relative
path it searches up the directory tree
looks in all the node modules directory
to find that particular JavaScript
module so when Marco finds a custom
element that it a custom tag that it
doesn't recognize it will search up the
directory tree to see if that custom tag
has an implementation in one of those
directories and then call out to it
automatically if it doesn't find it
you'll get an error at compile time so
just to kind of prove to you that Marco
is fast we created a lot of benchmarks
so I think this is this is actually for
like a color picker we have another
bench more [ __ ] mark for like search
results but we benchmarked it for
server-side rendering also on desktop
browsers as well as for mobile web
browsers and we compared it to to the
popular other UI libraries out there and
we found that in our benchmarks we tried
to be as fair as possible we
consistently outperformed the the
competition but of course every
benchmark varies and we tried to keep
our benchmarks as real-world as possible
based on our use cases at eBay oh and I
just to point out here oh so we actually
considered using react at eBay but at a
baby we do a lot of server-side
rendering and that's a key part of our
we it's it's we found to be very
important for performance and SEO so
react does not do at well at all on the
server
it's like 10x slower than Marco and it's
because generating a virtual Dom tree is
and then having to serialize that
virtual Dom tree to HTML is very slow
Wow
and so Marco has a very different way of
doing that same thing all right so why
is Marco fast so I just want to quickly
show you the compiled output so you can
see why Marco is fast so when we compile
a template for the server side we
generate code that is optimized for
streaming so here you can see out that
right and we're working with strings and
we're writing that out directly to the
stream so this same template compiled
for the browser generates a different
program that instead of rendering to a
stream will render to a virtual Dom tree
but the output is going to be the same
you're going to end up updating the Dom
and producing the same result so marco
also has a really smart compiler so we
can do static code analysis and find
portions of your template that are
completely static and when we find that
there's no reason to generate these
virtual Dom trees nodes every single
time we just create it once and store it
in a variable and then for every render
we use that so we apply a lot of
optimizations so that pages perform
really well when rendering with Marco so
the last thing I'm going to show you is
so Marco tries to solve this interesting
problem where if you we want to support
both server-side rendering and
client-side rendering but if you render
on the server you want the browser
basically to pick off pick up where the
server left off so if you create this
render this componentry on the server
you
need to recreate the componentry in the
browser so that you can then create
those component instances to handle the
events and so what we do with Marco is
that we will automatically basically
serialize the top-level input and state
so that we can recreate the component
tree but you don't have to think about
as a developer it just your page works
whether you render on the server or in
the browser so that's all I have a pleat
you can find some info about Marco here
it's on github open source
please start if you find it interesting
but any questions